>>Adam Lashinsky: A couple of caveats I'm
gonna steal a line from a telephone executive
who would like to say I know it's common to
ask people to shut down their phones but he
liked to hear the sound of ringing and so
he encouraged people to leave their phones
on.
Rather than ask you to put down your laptops
or your Smartphones I will say that if you
are looking into a screen I'm assuming you're
gonna be posting to Google+ about how interesting
this is and encouraging people to buy the
book and that' s just fine with me.
My other caveat is that although I do have
direct comparisons in the book between Apple
and Google and they will be part of my comments
and I am happy to discuss them with you in
the Q and A, I didn't spend the last year
of my life studying Google, I spent the last
year of my life studying Apple.
So beyond the conclusions that I am willing
to draw or the observations that I am willing
to make about the comparisons of the two companies,
in particular cultural issues, I don't wanna
put too much of the compare and contrast burden
on me for comparing Apple and Google, I'll
put that burden on you and I'll tell you about
Apple and leave you to make your own conclusions
about the differences between the two companies.
One of my major epiphanies in working on the
book and on the article in Fortune Magazine
before it is just how differently Apple does
business from the way everybody else does
business.
And indeed how the Apple way of doing business
is different from what's taught in business
school.
And Steve Jobs was quite clear on this, he
didn't particularly care for business school
and he didn't particularly care for MBA's
in general.
And part of the reason for doing Apple University
over the past four years was to as he put
it, "To try to create our own kind of MBA."
And so I'll ask you to keep in mind as I make
my points how much Apple differs from everybody
else.
The question arises, well if they're so exceptional
and they're so unique and they had this extraordinary
one of a kind leader how much can we learn
from them?
And I would suggest there absolutely is a
don't try this at home aspect to Apple's way
of doing business.
Having said that Apple is currently the world's
most valuable company and is absolutely crushing
it in a way and growing in a way that no large
company does, and maybe no large company ever
has and so I would submit that if they do
things differently it's at least worth asking
the question how and why.
And I really wish we had one of those set
ups where we could pan the room because I
just love people sitting on the floor for
a talk –
[laughter]
wonderful.
A moment on what Apple was like in 1997 when
Steve Jobs returned to the company.
He would be quoted frequently and in ensuing
years talking about the fact that Apple was
90 days from insolvency when he rejoined the
company in 1997.
The company was a shambles; it had too many
factories in the United States and abroad,
it had too much inventory, it had too many
middle managers, Jobs went on to fire about
4,000 of them.
The culture in his opinion had become infected
with people who were more interested in making
money than they were in making beautiful products,
and the company was structurally dysfunctional
in a way that he would change.
And the example that I share in the book is
that at the time Apple had 16 advertising
budgets.
Now the adverting budgets is a good metaphor
for fiefdoms; if you were a general manager
in the business and you had an advertising
budget that probably wasn't the only budget
that you had, you were an important person
in your own right.
Jobs wanted to eliminate that, he wanted to
get rid of fiefdoms, he got rid of the whole
notion of general manager, and he wanted to
emphasize the notion of one company, one brand,
one Apple, and so on.
And in eliminating the advertising budgets
he was able to say to people who were responsible
for a product, "If you think your product
deserves advertising spend then you'll come
to me and ask for advertizing spend and I'll
decide whether or not to give it to you and
we'll make a decision at a central, at a corporate
level about how to advertise."
And we all know how that's gone for Apple.
This was not about cost cutting by the way;
within short order advertising spending at
Apple increased it didn't decrease and Apple
developed this very virtuous circle of tending
to only advertise one or two major things
at a time, but there being a halo effect to
the other products that weren't being advertised
and this worked particularly well once the
stores were up and running and became a force
of their own.
Advertise an iPod and people might come in
and buy an iPhone; advertize the iPhone and
people have to walk past the Macintosh's to
get to the iMac's or the laptops to get to
the iPhone and so on.
And so that's something that Jobs cleaned
up in his first few years back at the company
in '97.
Leadership is an important topic when thinking
about Apple, it's also an example of Apple's
exceptionalism.
This is Narcissus the Greek god who was in
love with his own image; here he is gazing
into the pond to see his own beautiful self.
And I just wanted to share the work of a psychotherapist
and business coach named Michael Maccoby who
wrote a Harvest Business School article and
then a book called Narcissistic Leaders.
And as I was reading this article it goes
on explaining what a narcissist is first of
all, a narcissist is someone who is visionary,
who is charismatic, who has a willingness
to bet the company on his or her vision, who
expects to be followed but doesn't necessarily
care if they're loved.
And as I was readin' this I was thinking,
"My God this person is describing Steve Jobs
without using his name."
And then in fact Jobs did appear as an example
in Maccoby's work.
The productive narcissist, and I mentioned
that Maccoby was a business coach and a trained
psychotherapist, the productive narcissist
is someone who can channel their narcissism
in a productive way and he worked with clients
to help them be not less narcissistic but
more productively narcissistic.
And I think that if you dig into this topic
you see that a lot of what makes Apple tick
is because it has been led by this kind of
personality.
What then you ask happens after the productive
narcissist is gone?
Well there's two other categories that Maccoby
identifies as business people and he uses
classical Jungian psychological terms for
this.
The second category is an obsessive and he
talked about productive obsessives, these
are people who make the trains run on time,
they're typically a side kick to the productive
narcissist, they can help the visionary realize
their vision by executing it.
Tim Cook is a classic, the current CEO of
Apple, is a classic productive obsessive and
he's been in that role at Apple as Jobs' sidekick
for 10 years and now we'll see how the productive
obsessive can do as the CEO.
There are obsessive's as CEO's of other companies,
but Apple is very much characterized by this
narcissistic led organization.
There's a third category, by the way, that
will be of interest to people in the room
because I noticed that the CEO isn't in the
room and that is, unless I'm mistaken then
I apologize Larry.
[laughter]
His third category it's called erotics, an
erotic is someone who in the Jungian sense
is someone who does feel a need to be loved,
who does not necessarily like to be criticized
and wants approval.
This is an excellent person to have on a team,
not necessarily the person that you want running
the company.
[laughter]
One of the essential teachings of the modern
business era is that business leaders should
empower their people, they should push decisions
down into the organization, they should give
people the rope to hang themselves and to
execute the strategy of the company.
This is not how Apple does things.
Steve Jobs was a classic micromanager and
the people beneath him micromanaged the people
beneath them.
No detail is beneath their attention.
I know I mentioned that he was a narcissist
but he also had obsessive characteristics
as well.
And I discussed this with Maccoby by the way,
I asked Maccoby what he was and he said, "Well
I'm mostly an obsessive but I've got some
narcissistic tendencies to me as well."
And my example of it I discuss in the book
is an exchange that Jobs had with the marketing
executive whose job it was to send out an
email concurrent with a keynote launch of
a product.
And this person would email Jobs days before
the keynote to say, "Here's the email that
will go out."
And Jobs would object to the grammar in the
email getting down to the placement of a comma
or a semicolon and they would go back repeatedly
17 times until they got it right.
To me this is bizarre behavior but not inconsistent
with the micromanagement that Apple embraces.
I believe, by the way, from my conversations
that Jobs' opinion on the placement of the
comma was wrong --
[laughter]
but that doesn't matter and I think that's
obvious.
He obviously was very interested in language
but not a grammarian as we know from the Think
Different campaign.
[laughter]
A major part of my book and my research on
Apple is analyzing its secrecy.
I've been able to turn the what was a disadvantage
for me in writing a book about a company that
it's very secretive into a thesis point about
the company.
And my line is that every company keeps secrets
but at Apple everything is a secret and Apple
is particularly good at keeping secrets.
[laughter]
They have a hint of a sense of humor about
secrecy; this is an actual T-shirt that you
can buy at the company store in Cupertino
which is open to the public, "I visited the
Apple campus.
But that's all I'm allowed to say."
[laughter]
I will say it's the one example of a sense
of humor that I've been able to find at Apple
--
[laughter]
but I'm appreciative of it, very appreciative.
There is a sense of a culture of fear at Apple,
I've heard this from many, many employees
and I'll say in anticipation of a question
that I typically get is: who are my sources
for the book?
My sources are people typically who worked
at Apple at all levels of the organization,
very senior, very junior, and in between,
and compared with Walter Isaacson's biography
of Steve Jobs which is very much a view from
the top, I think that the perspective of a
junior person, for example, is very valid
in understanding how a company actually operates.
And secrecy is so important at Apple that
people are afraid to deviate from the secrecy.
And the hallmark of this is new employee orientation
which is every Monday at Apple, except as
I was told with a straight face when Monday
comes on a holiday.
That the security briefing is part of new
employee orientation and new employees are
told in a very matter of fact way, "Secrecy
is important here, it's worth money and measured
in the hundreds of millions of dollars from
the benefit that we get when a product is
launched and retribution will be severe is
you breach the rules of secrecy.
Termination obviously, maybe you'll be sued
as well."
And this is on your first day of work at Apple.
[laughter]
So why keep secrets?
The first one is good basic business in my
opinion.
You don't want your competitors knowing what
you're doing, you also don't want customers
knowing what you're doing until you're good
and ready to tell them.
Now this is a debatable topic in the Internet
world and in the Web world and we can discuss
it with as much time as we have, but Apple's
very clear on the subject.
Customers, the world, but customers in particular,
should learn about products the day that they're
released by us and not a moment before then.
And there's good Silicon Valley precedent
on this; other companies have fallen afoul
of the basic rule of if you've got products
on the shelf in retailer's stores and even
more seriously if you've got product in warehouses,
the last thing you want is customers believing
that a new version is coming soon because
who's gonna buy a product that's sitting on
shelves when a new version is coming soon?
And even Apple hasn't been perfect about this;
quarter before last they acknowledged that
iPhone 4 sales were hurt because the public
expected an iPhone 5.
They didn't get it, they were very disappointed
about this, they got the iPhone 4S instead
and it hurt Apple so badly that they went
on to sell 37 million iPhones in the last
quarter and rang up a $13 billion profit.
But the quarter before that they did acknowledge
that the rumor mill had had a negative impact.
But that's among the reasons anyway for keeping
secrets to outsiders.
But what I've realized in studying the company
is that Apple takes internal secrecy as seriously
as it does external secrecy.
And I've likened Apple employees to a horse
fitted with blinders; you don't look left,
you don't look right, you charge forward at
Apple and you don't multi-task by the way.
It has been humbling for me when I came to
realize how focused Apple people are because
I'm a multi-tasker, I'm constantly doing many
things, and at Apple below a certain level
and that level is high you don't do many things,
you tend to do one thing.
I don't know if it's an unintended consequence
but a realization that I had on this topic
of internal secrecy is that I've been told
over and over and I've come to believe that
below a certain level again there's very little
politicking at Apple.
And that makes sense because how can you play
politics when you don't have the information
with which to play politics?
It is none of your business what I'm doing
[chuckles] and it's none of my business what
you're doing so what do we have to talk about?
And I skipped over an example on the outside
world; it's my belief from my 15 years in
Silicon Valley that engineers in particular
love to talk about what they do.
And by the way journalists love to talk about
what we do.
And we keep of course we keep secrets about
what stories we're working on, but we can
talk ad nauseam about craft and past stories
and whatnot.
And my understanding is that this is something
that Silicon Valley engineers enjoy engaging
in; Apple people are told not to.
And I describe in the book someone I know
who plays in a regular poker game with a group
of Apple people and this person does not work
at Apple and when the subject of Apple comes
up at the poker table the subject is changed.
And so I've described Apple not only metaphorically
as the ultimate need-to-know culture but literally
as the ultimate need-to-know culture.
And this manifests itself in interesting linguistic
ways and also in physical ways.
So Apple is a culture of disclosure.
I say to you, "Are you disclosed on the following?"
and I have to do a little kabuki if I don't
know if you're disclosed on it, I can't exactly
say what it is.
But if everyone in a meeting isn't disclosed
then not everyone is welcome at the meeting.
And this is true also in a physical sense
and I describe in the book how you'll be working
and all of a sudden barriers go up, windows
that were clear become frosted, doors that
didn't exist now exist, security badges that
once got you in to a certain area no longer
get you into the area.
And if you're a typical worker what you know
is that there's a new project underfoot and
that's all you know.
If you knew you're badge would get you into
that area and it doesn't.
And most interestingly to me I've been told
again more than once, people telling me that
their bosses did not have access to the same
areas that they had access to for reasons
that they didn't necessarily understand.
This is an org chart that I created first
in Fortune Magazine in May of last year, it's
actually highly accurate but you're not expected
to be able to read the fine print from where
you're sitting.
But the key is this, and I like to say that
candidly this was more dramatic when Steve
Jobs, the Sun King, was at the center and
the planets were revolving around him.
This is in fact how Apple operates but I think
one of the great unknowns is how it will continue
to operate with Cook as the CEO or whoever
follows him.
But what you can see from this is what you
might expect from Apple an incredibly tight
and an incredibly focused org chart where
the CEO, this ring around the inner circle
are the vice presidents of Apple and I've
got most but not all of them there.
It's a very small number of vice presidents
and the CEO can reach down no more than one
layer to really touch just about everything
that's going on at the company.
As part of the culture, by the way, you won't
be surprised to learn that org charts are
frowned up at Apple; Apple doesn't create
and print org charts.
And I was told that people were visibly nervous
having my org chart from Fortune Magazine
on their desks last year.
Apple's famous for sweating the details and
the example I give in the book is the packaging
design room where a package designer had hundreds
of prototypes of iPod boxes and their sole
mission, and Apple teaches this, this case
by the way is an example of attention to detail.
This person's sole mission was to peel off
that little piece of clear tape that seals
your box and do this over and over and make
sure that the placement was just perfect.
Now it sounds silly except, and I won't ask
for a show of hands because it could be incriminating,
but is there anyone in the room who has experienced
the joy of peeling off that piece of tape
and opening their iPod or iPhone box and taking
the product out and seeing how everything
is laid perfectly and then taking their device
out and feeling this sense of joy?
[laughter]
Okay, I do have smiles and chuckles in the
room, maybe some nervous laughter.
But this is just one example and this pervades
the organization and so you get a sense of
why details are important at Apple.
Jobs was famous for saying that he didn't
think that Apple should do customer research
and instead how could customers possibly know
what they wanted when they don't know what
the product is that we're going to give them,
and we'll give them the products that we think
they should have.
By the way, Jobs especially later in life
like many of us was famous for repeating the
same lines over and over again and this was
one of his favorites because it resonated
so well because it's exactly the opposite
of how other people, how other companies do
things.
We now know that integration is key to the
Apple's excellence and the integration that
this typically refers to, and it's something
that Jobs spoke about, was the integration
of hardware and software.
And it's sort of astounding that over the
past 15 years really only Apple has been particularly
excellent at integrating its own hardware
and software and its competitors have been
bifurcated in hardware and software.
But my point is that the whole company is
integrated extremely well, Apple is not whimsical
as its advertising might suggest but extremely
planned, extremely well organized, things
happen according to a timeline that is written
down, and the various parts of the company
work well together in the past by force of
will because Jobs made sure that people worked
well together.
But a key to understanding Apple is the importance
of design.
And again Jony Ive has become famous as the
head of industrial design at Apple, but what's
less well understood is just how important
his seat at the table has been.
And you can glean this from the fact that
at Apple it would be inconceivable for say
a financial person to sit in on the same early
product development meeting where Jony Ive
or Jony Ive's people would have a conversation
about what the product would look like.
Steve Jobs, at least initially, would have
been completely uninterested in a finance
person's opinion of what it might cost to
do that or how we might pay for it or what
kind of revenue we might be able to get from
it; this is antithetical to the Apple way
of thinking.
I likened it to a corollary to the personal
maxim of, "Do what you love and the money
will follow."
It's a little corny, I have to refine that
but it really does I think express Jobs' approach
to product was, "First we'll think of the
product, then we'll think of how to make it
beautiful and how to make it really good,
then we'll figure out what the market is for
it."
And I would submit to you that's not the normal
decision making process at your typical big
company.
A hallmark of Apple's entire way of doing
business is the power of saying no, and this
is across the business and across product
development.
It says no to industries to get involved in,
to who it will sell to, we know that it's
been famously uninterested in selling to big
businesses over the years, which by the way
has some history.
Apple got beaten up badly in the 80's selling
to the enterprise and this scarred Jobs, many
things scarred Jobs including this almost
running out of cash at the beginning.
I have to tell you that I showed this slide
at Microsoft last week and I --
[laughter]
prepared them and I said, "Please don't take
this the wrong way," but I think it's very
telling.
What you get when you open your box of a PC
that you got at a retailer and what you get
when you open your iMac box.
I wanna do another slide that focuses more
on the screen because I think it's in the
book and it's a very important part of Apple's
mentality of saying, "No."
You know what the screen on an iMac looks
like when you turn it on, I need to show what
the screen of a PC looks like especially if
you buy it from a retailer, your screen is
littered with what Jobs referred as, "Crapware."
And Crapware are these icons from various
vendors that the retailers or the manufacturers
have done a deal with to goose their margin
a little bit.
I would suggest that it's nothing short of
insulting to the customer to put that on the
screen and it's something Apple wouldn't dream
of doing.
Apple has faults by the way, but this is something
Apple's very good at.
I could go on about the beauty of saying no;
Jobs would say that saying no is more important
than saying yes.
This extends to how Apple cooperates or engages
with the rest of the world.
Most companies will send its people out to
events to interact in the hope that there
might be some intangible benefit from interacting.
Apple even killed the trade show that it was
integral to starting although it was its own,
Macworld.
And then I just like showing this fanciful
slide of an Apple executive being in a chair
at the World Economic Forum in Davos where
I was a few weeks ago.
It's inconceivable to think of an Apple person
engaging in jawboning and talking about making
the world a better place in Davos.
[laughter]
With what's going on I shouldn't say inconceivable,
but it's until now impossible and I think
highly unlikely in the near future.
You will know by the way if you see the CEO
of Apple on stage in Davos that things have
really changed at Apple.
Apple has this concept of the directly responsible
individual.
It’s one of these things when I first heard
about it, first of all Apple people have been
talking about for years this pre-dates Jobs'
return in 1997, it's not completely clear
to me that it was even language that Jobs
was all that familiar with which magnifies
its importance to me that it's so important
at Apple.
At Apple there will be a list of items on
the agenda for a meeting, for example, and
next to the action item will be a name, that
name is the DRI; the DRI is the one person
whose job it is to get the job done on that
specific task.
It's so simple, it's so obvious, and yet my
hunch and I'm gonna try to test this with
business school professors, is that most businesses
don't do it.
And I know that I, oops, I don't know what
that's about.
My Outlook is open, I apologize.
I know there was a period when I was working
on the article at Fortune that I started to
become obnoxious within my own company by
asking, "Well who's the DRI on that?"
This was often on the telephone because most
of my colleagues are in New York, but I could
feel the eyes rolling when I said it.
I think it's unique that Apple is a massively
functional organization; this is the corollary
to Jobs' aversion to general management; he
did not want jacks of all trades running businesses
within the business, he wanted experts.
He would brag that Apple employs the best
metallurgists in the world.
And this is the case throughout the organization.
This is I think one of the most important
and most controversial aspects of how Apple
does business in that in selected instances
it behaves like a start-up.
Of course Apples is not a start-up, I'm not
so naive as to think that it is; there are
many elements of the company that behave just
like any big business anywhere.
But where it's relevant, where Apple decides
that it's going to create something new and
do something fresh, it manages to hive off
an area and let a relatively small group of
people behave as if they are at a start-up.
And I've likened this to a bunch of rich kids
in that they're off in a corner doing their
own thing, but they have a very wealthy parent
funding their research, and in Apple's case
this is a nearly $100 billion balance sheet
funding their research.
I think by now since I wrote about it last
May it's become well known that Apple thinks
a lot about the notion of small numbers.
The British anthropologist Robin Dunbar referred
to the Dunbar's number as being about 150
or smaller, that most humans really can't
relate to a group of people much bigger than
about 150.
He was looking at primates in the wild, by
the way, but he decided that that was applicable
to humans as well.
And in fact for years Apple has been having
this ultra top secret retreat of about 100
people whom Jobs characterized as the people
he would want to take with him if he were
to leave Apple, the 100 or so most important
people.
Very interestingly to me, by the way, this
was not a rank thing with Jobs it was not
a status thing it was who he literally thought
were the most important people, not necessarily
by title.
The stories about the top 100 are legendary
and typical Apple; Jobs would require everybody
attending the meeting to be bussed down to
the Santa Cruz or Monterey area in a bus from
Cupertino.
And I had this image of certain senior executives
who had attained great wealth being forced
to get on a bus and drive for an hour and
a half or a couple of hours because the boss
didn't want them driving their own car.
He would sweep the room for bugs beforehand,
legitimately paranoid that the competition
might try to find out the secrets that were
going to be revealed at a top 100 meeting.
And indeed products for the next 18 months
or so have been revealed at top 100 meetings.
Given how secretive Apple is Jobs thought
that it was important for a slightly larger
group than the 10 or so person executive team
to be exposed to what was coming down the
pike.
The rest of the company was not invited to
the meeting and would not be exposed.
One of the fascinating elements of this secrecy
that I've learned, the sales people at Apple
are particularly frustrated because they don't
find out about what's going on at the company
in terms of new products any sooner than the
rest of us do.
And if you think about again how different
that is from any normal company which obviously
wants to prep the sales force so they can
sell the product that's coming.
On the subject of exclusion, I'm also told
that Apple people to this day will gather
in a cafeteria to watch a closed circuit television
broadcast of the major keynotes whether it's
at Moscone or on their own campus because,
and I think this is so interesting, they’re
learning about the product that's being revealed
for the very first time at the same time the
public is, at the same time journalists are.
This includes people who worked on the product
because they typically will only have seen
the feature or the part of the feature that
they worked on.
Apple's marketing I think it's fair to say
is brilliant; one of the premises of the marketing
at Apple is staying on the script.
I hope I'm not gushing too much and suggesting
that “1,000 songs in your pocket” is one
of the more brilliant marketing lines in the
history of consumer electronics marketing.
Obviously MP3 players existed before the existing,
the incumbent's stressed storage capacity
of their devices, Apple did talk about storage
capacity in terms of pricing, but “1,000
songs in your pocket”, who can't understand
that and who can't repeat it over and over?
And that's another important that you'd think
would be normal in business but I think Apple
does it better than most.
I've described how first of all very few people
at Apple are allowed to speak publicly; it's
a discreet, finite number that is defined
in preparation for a product launch and the
language that they will use is preapproved
and agreed upon.
And so I quote an executive who was approved
on the iPhone who explained to me in giving
speeches on my book I can understand the mentality
that when you give this message over and over
the intellectual or human tendency is to change
up your delivery because that's how you keep
yourself entertained.
But he said, "No when you're pitching an Apple
product you deliver it over and over exactly
the way we agreed it was gonna be delivered.
Why?
Well because the listener's hearing it for
the first time and what we want is for the
listener to repeat it to their friends and
for their friends to start repeating it and
pretty soon it's being repeated back in the
marketplace exactly the way we wrote it."
And it's a very pure and very understandable
approach when you think about it that way,
but requires a ton of discipline.
Sometimes I've described Apple as a company
of paradoxes because on the one hand Apple
is described to me, Apple people describe
Apple as being resource constrained.
I came to understand what they're really referring
to is people; it's very difficult to get enough
of the right people on a project.
But when Apple decides to make a product or
market a product they will spend whatever
it takes for seemingly trivial expenditures.
And so the story I tell in the book is of
Jobs' desire to illustrate iMovie HD in 2005,
the first launch of the high def version of
iMovie.
And there weren't a lot of HD cameras or HD
televisions in the marketplace at the time
so he decided they should do a wedding because
he knew that people used iMovie to shoot weddings.
So they shot a wedding, it was an Apple employee;
it was a beautiful, elegant affair at the
Officers Club at the Presidio in San Francisco.
Only when Jobs decided his opinion was it
was too elegant, it was too stuffy and he
said, "I want a beach, I want feet in the
sand, I want a tropical setting, Hawaii would
be good."
He was fond of Hawaii.
This was three weeks before Macworld.
And to make a long story short, finding a
beautiful actress who was getting married
on Maui right before New Years', the team
got its image at tremendous expense and the
expense was really irrelevant; this was for
a 30 second or so clip at Macworld; they were
able to show iMovie HD in beautiful, emotional
terms; the money wasn't what mattered.
So just to drive home the point, this is a
replica of an actual wall in a marketing building
at Apple; if you're in this marketing group
after you go in the door in the morning you
walk around this wall every single day on
your way to work to remind you what your approach
to marketing should be at Apple.
Only this isn't exactly how the wall appears,
this is.
Apple has an interesting relationship with
the press and that includes me and I think
there's a profound business point here; there's
only one subject generally that Apple views
worthy of it discussing publicly and that's
its products; doesn't wanna talk about how
it does business which is the subject of my
book, it doesn't wanna by and large with the
exception of Steve Jobs it doesn't wanna talk
about personalities, it doesn't wanna get
involved in lifestyle issues of Apple, of
Apple people, and so on.
So it keeps the press at arm's length with
two kind of amusing exceptions and that's
David Pogue at the New York Times and Walt
Mossberg at the Wall Street Journal.
Apple will go to great lengths to keep the
two of them happy and I encourage you to read
the section in my book where I discuss that.
Apple also, by the way, is very tuned into
the importance of celebrity and that celebrities
play an important role in your image.
And I describe in the book the day that Harry
Connick, Jr. emailed Steve Jobs because he
had a problem with his monitor and this is
called an escalation.
Jobs emailed Cook, Cook emailed a senior executive
in the supply chain organization who emailed
a junior executive in the supply chain organization,
who got Harry Connick, Jr. his new monitor
in a matter of a half hour or so.
[laughter]
And my very last point, and this can sort
of serve as a jumping off point to discuss
the future of Apple, one of these paradoxes
about Apple is that it behaves in quite an
entrepreneurial way and the risks it's taken
and the new products it's come out with in
the last 15 years have been a triumph of entrepreneurialism
I would suggest.
However, one of the sort of glaring realizations
I made toward the end of writing the book
is that really the great entrepreneur at Apple
was Steve Jobs and in fact his family listed
entrepreneur on his death certificate.
The most important remaining members of the
executive team are not entrepreneurs.
I mean Tim Cook bled IBM Blue for gosh sakes
for the first 10 plus years of his career.
He loves Apple but he's not an entrepreneur.
Scott Forstall who runs the mobile software
has only worked for two companies in his career
and both of them were headed by Steve Jobs;
the first was NeXT.
Jony Ive has been quoted publicly saying that
when he ran his own design consultancy in
London it was called Tangerine, and I think
it's really interesting that the two great
companies of his career are Tangerine and
Apple.
[laughter]
Commented that he didn't really care for the
business aspect of running Tangerine, he wanted
to design and boy has he done a great job
of designing.
[chuckles]
But I leave you to think about what will be
the meaning of an Apple that isn't led by
someone who identifies as an entrepreneur.
I invite you to look at my brand new Website
and as well as I put my Twitter handle up
there and I would love to see some engagement
on my Google+ profile as well and I'm happy
to do that with you and to take your questions
for 15 minutes.
There's a mic right there.
So thank you very much.
[applause]
>>male #1: Hello.
Hey Adam thanks a lot for the talk.
So I actually have two questions: one question
is like on your second slide you mentioned
like everything Apple did is like quite contradict
to what we learned in business school, so
does this mean like, I don’t think, like,
people, me, like what we learned in business
school is wrong or like Apple is just like
absolutely by chance it's a great success,
so what things we can learn from the success
of Apple from both like say in academia or
in business world so what thing we can really
take from Apple?
>>Adam Lashinsky: Sure.
So, thank you, so first of all I think that
I am saying that in Apple's opinion some of
the things that you learn in business school
are in fact wrong.
But I'm not suggesting that that's an absolute,
and I think that companies and people have
to go down the list and consider each one
and say, "Is this something that my company
or that I can emulate at Apple or is this
something that's unique to Apple?"
And I'll give you one example of one of these
teachings that I think that all companies
can think about.
I mean some companies have to be revenue optimizers
that's just the way they're set up, they've
gotta think about cash flow because maybe
that's their best bet, but other companies
can take an approach that thinking about the
revenue first is the wrong way.
I also think that there isn't a company out
there of any size and in any industry that
can't ask itself the question, "Are we saying
no often enough?
Have we said no in each instance where it
might have made sense to say no instead of
yes?
That's one example I think.
>>male #1: Yeah.
Thank you.
One more question about like how I remember
you have one slide about the integration.
So we know like Apple is, uh…very few company
that like do everything in a single chain
within one company for example from the design,
manufacture, operating system, and retail,
and marketing.
So what's the reason do you think like they
did a great job in operation and management
for like integrate every parts like become
a world leader not only in every area but
also integrate very well in every part?
>>Adam Lashinsky: So I'll give you, I'm gonna
give you two answers and the first one is
sort of cynical and is the conventional wisdom.
The answer to your first question, why are
they so good at integrating?
You can answer in two words: Steve Jobs.
And there's a very strong current of thought
within Apple including people who believe
that the company will not fare well going
forward that he was completely responsible
for this integration through sheer force of
brutal will and that that will be far more
difficult after he's gone, with him gone.
And then the more hopeful response is that
he developed a system where the culture of
the company includes this integration run
by the executive team and the CEO and that
this is a process at Apple.
And I think this is, this will be one of the
great questions of the next call it five years
that will be answered: will they be able to
integrate as well without him or not?
>>male #1: Thanks.
>>Adam Lashinsky: Thank you.
>>male #2: Hi, I had a question about Pixar.
I wonder if you got any chance to compare
the way Apple as a corporation is run compared
to Pixar which is also I guess like Steve
Jobs' --
>>Adam Lashinsky: Sure.
>>male #2: step child.
>>Adam Lashinsky: So relatively little, I
mean I read a very fine book called The Pixar
Touch by David Price which is a great history
of the company, very precise in terms of going
over what happened for Pixar to become Pixar,
including the fact that when Jobs bought Pixar
the Pixar assets from George Lucas neither
he nor anyone else had any clue that it was
gonna be an important feature film company
down the road; that was an accident which
he absolutely deserves credit for recognizing.
But I didn't study Pixar for my book and this
question has come up so my only observation
would be that Jobs was never the day-to-day
CEO of, number one of Pixar, he was the CEO
for a time but he never spent all his time
there.
And number two the culture of Pixar for the
culture of Pixar, Ed Catmull and John Lasseter
are extremely important to the way the company
operates and the way the company thinks in
the way that Jobs was for the '97 to '11 period
at Apple.
But that's as deeply as I can go on Pixar.
>>male #2: Okay, thanks
>>Adam Lashinsky: Thanks.
>>male #3: So this might be a controversial
question --
>>Adam Lashinsky: Good.
>>male #3: if you look at the top management
of Apple it's glaring that it's only white
male.
And unlike other beta companies there are
no Indians and no Chinese, there are no women,
there are no African Americans, no one.
Is it part of the culture of secrecy that
intends a white male to become a top of top
manager versus --
>>Adam Lashinsky: I understand your question;
all I can tell you is that I haven't had that
question before which suggests to me only
that it's not a top of mind conversation at
Apple.
I have had the question about the paucity
of female executives, there are no female
executives on the executive team, there are
quite a handful in the vice president level,
but I don't know how that would compare statistically,
I actually think it would compare probably
comparably to statistics in corporate America,
but obviously not the college graduate education
by any means.
So I'll just give you, so I don't have anything
great to say about it.
I'll give you a tangential point that I make
in the book and this is in contrast as I understand
it to Google, Apple is a headquarters centric,
face-to-face meeting oriented company where
meetings happen with people looking at each
other not over teleconference or video conference;
people travel but they come back to Cupertino
for the important meetings.
So now I'm theorizing, if a face-to-face headquarters
culture engenders homogeneity that may be
your answer, but I'm not gonna state it in
any sort of declarative way 'cause it's neither
something that I've studied nor have a strong
opinion on.
>>male #4: Thanks for all the fascinating
insights, when are you gonna do your book
on Google?
[laughter]
>>Adam Lashinsky: Well two very fine writers
Ken Auletta and Steven Levy have written Google
books in recent memory, so I'll let their
insights die down before I consider the fresh
insights.
>>male #4: That was actually my joke questions.
But --
[laughter]
>>Adam Lashinsky: Oh.
>>male #4: this could be serious, but --
>>Adam Lashinsky: I have other reasons why
that's not gonna be my next book.
>>male #4: we're all Googlers here but from
your non-Googlers perspective how would you
compare and contrast Google versus Apple?
>>Adam Lashinsky: Well culturally I've described
the companies as the opposites in almost every
single way so from a --
[laughter]
cultural perspective as stated by its own
beliefs and I believe practices, Google believes
in openness, Apple does not [chuckles].
Google is predicated on the World Wide Web
and ancillary technologies, Apple is not.
There is a subtle similarity I believe in
the way I've heard Larry and Sergey describe
the graduate school environment of bitter
arguments over substantive issues in getting
to the best answer.
That also characterizes Apple and I quote
somebody in the book saying, "You bring your
arguments about product, you bring your data
about product into an argument at Apple and
if you're data is the best thing for the product
you win."
It's not a beauty contest in that regard or
a popularity contest.
So I would say those two are similar but where
the debate happens, I think the debate is
a much more senior level closed debate at
Apple and a broader, more inclusive debate
at Google.
And then there's this fundamental product
difference in orientation and I describe it
in the book and I came to realize that this
description of Google was based on a blog
post that a departing engineer wrote about
how Google would make, or how Google did make
decisions about color pallets for example
on a webpage, which was to try several shades
of blue for example and then analyze the click
through rates on a million clicks on google.com
to choose the right shade.
And I believe this person was expressing frustration
but I'm not gonna criticize that because I
think it is a fundamental difference and an
important way, an important aspect of decision
making at Google.
And at Apple over the last 15 years the way
the color pallet decision was made is that
people would show Steve Jobs various shades
of blue and he would choose the one --
[laughter]
that he thought was right.
Very, very different and we could go on for
three hours on the differences.
Thank you.
>>male #5: So I saw earlier that you don't
use a Mac, are there any Apple products that
you do use and were there any that you started
to use after you wrote the book that you didn't
before?
>>Adam Lashinsky: I'm ready for this one.
[laughter]
First of all I do use a Mac, I'm just not
using one today and I will have this presentation
in Keynote, I just don't have it yet in Keynote,
long story, details aren't interesting, the
details are not interesting.
Yeah, I have an iMac at home, I have an iPhone
that's turned off sitting over here, I have
an iPad, I have an iPod and in fact, and I'll
tell ya I have no problem telling you the
thing that keeps me with a PC is Outlook.
Being a journalist the information's very
important to me and my Outlook is extremely
important to me and everyone criticizes Outlook
on the Mac as being an inferior product and
so I'm scared to go over to it full time.
But however, there's a serious point here
and I make it toward the end of the book which
is that when I joined Fortune, actually Fortune
editorial is a Mac shop and the business side
is a PC shop and I insisted on having a PC,
this was 10 plus years ago because I was not
a Mac guy and I didn't wanna go through the
pain of shifting to a Mac; 10 years ago it
was a lot harder than it is now.
And over the years I've started using Mac
products, starting with iTunes and iPod and
so on, and I maintain that the reason Apple
is a $400 billion plus company today, it's
great success, is because of people like me
not because of the enthusiasts who were gonna
buy Apple products no matter what.
This is their great success is in selling
me stuff.
>>male #5: I have one other question: now
you say that Apple, I mean you can't be like
Apple, but who do you see as the next Apple,
and I don't mean the next Apple --
>>Adam Lashinsky: Yeah.
>>male #5: trying to be like Apple, but being
as wildly successful doing things their own
way, is there anyone on the horizon?
>>Adam Lashinsky: Well we could make up a
list of startups which I'm loath to do because
I think it's too risky and you end up looking
foolish talking about startups that could
be like Apple or doing things their own way
because they might be gone soon, although
I do get into this in the book, I have some
fun examples about how --
>>male #5: Sounds like I should buy the book.
>>Adam Lashinsky: I would hope so yeah.
[laughter]
I would wish you would buy five, but --
I'll give quick examples and then I'll answer
your question.
Ness Labs is very interesting run by an ex-Apple
executive and they are certainly doing some
very Apple-like things.
So is Tesla, its showroom strategy is not
like Apple retail, it is Apple retail and
it's run by an ex-Apple retail guy.
And I think the big company right now that
has the most similar characteristics to Apple
is Amazon.
I could list a bunch of things, the thing
that is most similar is the way Amazon truly
does not give a damn about what people think
of its short term strategy; Amazon is very
invested in the long term and I didn't say
it out loud today but Apple's a very long=term
oriented company.
Thanks, yeah.
>>female #1: From your research and experience
what makes Apple employees happy and what
makes them stay in the company?
>>Adam Lashinsky: Thank you.
There was a period in my reporting, in particular
for the magazine article, where I would go
and ask people, "Are Apple employees happy?"
And the standard response would be, "Apple
people tend to buy into the mission of the
company."
And I'd say, "Yes, but are they happy?"
[laughter]
And the response would be, "People take great
pride at Apple" [laughs]
[laughter]
in seeing their products used all over the
place," and so on.
And so I think it's not trivial or an understatement
to say that it helps, everyone want to be
on a winning team and you're willing to overlook
quite a bit to be on that winning team.
And I am not, I don't wanna suggest that Apple
is a joyless place because some people have
drawn that conclusion from some of the stuff
in my book about Apple as a workplace, but
I think it's fair to say that joy and fun
is not at the top of the list.
And I think again now trying to be non-judgmental
about this there's a certain purity about
this from a shareholder perspective or from
a customer perspective, would I settle for
a little bit less in ease of use, for example,
in exchange for a little more joy from the
workforce?
[laughter]
I don't know.
Should I take one more Bernadette or am I
done?
One more please.
Yeah.
>>male #6: Sorry I don't have a chance to
get over to the microphone.
Would you say that Apple's experience with
Foxconn in China is a result of their corporate
strategies and focus and the like or is that
sort of anomalous having to do with labor
conditions in general in China, does it come
from Apple or is Apple just sort of a semi-willing
participant.
>>Adam Lashinsky: So the question is, is Apple's
experience at Foxconn in China, essentially
I'll recraft your question, is it exceptional,
is it different from the industry?
And I have not gone deep on this topic so
my superficial understanding first of all
is that no their experiences in China are
similar to everybody else's experiences.
And if anything, and I am neither excusing
them nor criticizing them for what goes on
in China, but am observing that Apple culturally
is unused to being the top dog; they're unused
to the scrutiny of being number one; they
identify with being the underdog, so I think
they were shocked that they were being singled
out.
We'll find out if they're better or worse
than everybody else but I think if you look
at the New York Times' article that has put
this back on the agenda or has elevated this
on the agenda, the Times went to great length
to suggest that the article that it did on
the situation at Foxconn could have been written
about any of the big consumer electronics
manufacturers who used contract manufacturers
in China, which is all of them.
And you saw today that Apple has hired a third
party auditor to audit themselves again and
so we'll see how that goes.
>>Bernadette: Thank you so much Adam.
Please again join me in thanking Adam for
coming.
[applause]
>>Adam Lashinsky: Thank you.